>> Laura: YOU HEARD IT, I LAID
IT OUT IN THE TWO ANGLES.
THE ONE THING THE DEMOCRATS MADE
CLEAR IN THE SECOND ROUND OF
DEBATES AS THERE IS A CLEAR
DIVIDE BETWEEN THE RADICALS AND
JOE BIDEN.
HERE NOT TO BREAK DOWN THE WORDS
AND PHRASES THAT MATTERED IS
POSTER FRANK LUNTZ.
I WANT TO START WITH BIDEN, HE'S
BEING CALLED THE MODERATE ONE
BUT THERE WAS ONE RADICAL
SUGGESTION, WATCH.
>> I HAVE THE ONLY PLAN THAT
GIVES REASONABLE PRICES FLAT
OUT.
NUMBER TWO, WE SHOULD PUT SOME
OF THESE INSURANCE EXECUTIVES IN
JAIL FOR THE 9 BILLION OPIOIDS
THEY SELL OUT THERE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THAT?
>> DID YOU HEAR THE AUDIENCE
REACTION TO IT?
I WAS THERE IN THE HALL FOR BOTH
DEBATES AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR TO THE VIEWERS THIS IS NOT
A FIGHT FOR THE SOUL OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THAT FIGHT IS
OVER.
THE HOSTILITY OF THESE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES TO
CORPORATE AMERICA, TO CEOs TO
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IS SIGNIFICANT.
THE LANGUAGE I HEARD IN THE LAST
48 HOURS IS LANGUAGE I'VE NEVER
HEARD FROM ANY MAINSTREAM
DEMOCRAT, ANYTIME YOU WANT
ANTICORPORATE, ANTI-CEO,
ANTI-SUCCESS, THE AUDIENCE LIT
UP WITH APPLAUSE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO MOVE ON TO
NIGHT 1 AND SOMETHING SAID BY
BERNIE SANDERS IN WARREN THAT
STRUCK YOU, WATCH.
>> OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM IS
CORRUPTION, IT IS A GIANT
CORPORATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN OUR
GOVERNMENT AND HOLDING IT BY THE
THROAT AND WE NEED TO HAVE THE
COURAGE TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST
THAT.
>> ANYBODY HERE WHO THINKS
CORPORATE AMERICA GIVES ONE DAMN
ABOUT THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
WORKER, YOU'RE MISTAKEN.
STAND UP AND TAKE ON THE GREED
AND DESTRUCTION OF THE RULING
CLASS.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT WHAT
OBAMA SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO?
>> THIS IS SO MUCH MORE EXTREME.
HOLDING THE GOVERNMENT BY THE
THROAT, IT'S GRAPHIC, IT'S
VISUAL.
I SAY EVERY CEO WHO'S WATCHING
RIGHT NOW AND EVERY CORPORATE
EXECUTIVE, THEY ARE AFTER YOU.
THEY'RE BLAMING YOU, THEY ARE
HOLDING YOU ACCOUNTABLE.
I ATTENDED THE SEI YOU RALLY AND
WHAT THEY KEPT ON SAYING WAS NO
PEACE, NO JUSTICE.
NO PEACE, NO JUSTICE.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE LABOR
UNREST OVER THE NEXT YEAR.
YOU WILL HAVE CONTINUED DIVIDE
TO CORPORATE AMERICA AND ITS
PEOPLE, THE TENSION IN THE
WORKFORCE WILL BE FAR GREATER.
THERE'S A LESSON HERE THAT
ECONOMIC FREEDOM IS UNDER DIRECT
ATTACK AND I DON'T MEAN TO
OVERSTATE IT BUT IT IS
SIGNIFICANT.
>> Laura: THAT EMBATTLED NYC
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO, HE WAS
RANTING A LOT LAST NIGHT BUT
THIS MOMENT REALLY STOOD OUT,
WATCH.
>> THE RICH HAVE GOTTEN RICHER
AND THEY PAID LESS AND LESS IN
TAXES, IT CANNOT GO ON THIS WAY,
WE WILL EVEN UP THE SCORE AND WE
WILL PASS THE          TAX THE H
WILL PASS THE          TAX THE F
WILL PASS THE          TAX THE T
WILL PASS THE          TAX THE E
WEALTHY.
THIS HAS TO BE A PARTY THAT SAYS
WE ARE GOING TO TAX THE WEALTHY.
>> Laura: HE SAID IT TWICE
JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND.
>> THE AUDIENCE ERUPTED IN
APPLAUSE, THAT IS BEST MOMENT
AMONG DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT POLITICS,
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT WINNING
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
THIS IS ABOUT CHANGING THE
STRUCTURE OF THE ECONOMY IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO TURN IT UPSIDE
DOWN.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU, I'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS SINCE 1992, I'VE
NEVER HEARD CANDIDATES THIS
EXTREME, I'VE NEVER HEARD
CANDIDATES THIS HOSTILE TO
ECONOMIC FREEDOM AND THEY HAVE
THE BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ABSOLUTELY BEHIND THEM.
>> Laura: THEY ARE ANTIFREEDOM
ON WHAT KIND OF CAR YOU DRIVE,
WHETHER YOU CAN FLY SOMEWHERE,
AS LONG AS THEY ARE ABLE TO FLY
TO THEIR STUPID CONFERENCES